bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct ce matin sur rtl france ce lundi
donc l'arabie saoudite a proposé un
cessez le feu aux rebelles houthi une
proposition saluée par l'onu mais
pourquoi les rebelles houthi rejette
cette proposition
bonjour les rebelles houthi roger cette
solution parce que il n'y a rien de
nouveau vraiment dans cette solution
quelque chose qui a été apporté par
rapport à pourparlers qui étaient
effectués à ryad ya plus d'un an par
rapport à la recette de 102 107 22-16 de
l'onu elle par rapport à tout ce qui a
été proposé avant il n'y a pas vraiment
de réellement des changements selon les
outils pour lesquels ils peuvent pour
céder et accepter un échange est pas
aussi d'autres garanties des outils
savent très bien que l'arabie saoudite
était physique c'était une soluce ou un
pas vers l'avant pour essayer de s'en
sortir
2 il y pense vraiment que l'arabie
saoudite et l'iran n'est plus en
position de force et que les outils
aujourd'hui ils ont la possibilité de
négocier mieux la charte où les
conditions de cet arrêt de cessez-le-feu
d'inde d'un autre côté les outils savent
très bien qu'ils ont beaucoup à perdre
en acceptant cette proposition et ils
veulent vraiment faire partie des
négociations et non seulement accepté
une proposition qui est pour eux imposés
par l'arabie saoudite qui n'apporte rien
de nouveau
il est vrai que cette proposition il n'a
pas vraiment quelque chose de si je peux
appeler çà comme çà d'extraordinaire ou
de réellement
de réellement concret surtout que les
outils le prennent comme c'est une
solution plutôt est médiatique qu'une
solution réellement diplomatique aux
politiques que l'arabie saoudite essaie
de montrer au monde entier qu'elle est
en train de tendre la main aux outils et
elle veut le faire voir aussi au monde
entier que ils sont là pour trouver une
solution pour trouver la paix et il veut
montrer au monde que les outils ne
veulent pas accepter ni la paix ni les
solutions il ya même une condition des
rebelles houthis et la levée du blocus
sur le yémen par ryad ce que c'est
possible ou pas cela et quel est ce que
ça peut avoir comme conséquence
justement sur un éventuel cessez le feu
effectivement les hôtes ils veulent
absolument se lever le blocus par
rapport aux non seulement par rapport
aux et d'humanitaire mais aussi tout ce
qui est espace aérien espaces maritimes
et les outils veulent est pour mon et
veulent vraiment que les ravisseurs ont
fait ils disent que la vie sauve et on
aurait dû commencer par ça il faut pas
dissocier le cessez-le-feu avec tout un
panorama ou [ __ ] tout à une situation
qu'il faut composer avec brodé avec et
non seulement parler d'un cessez-le-feu
les outils et savent très bien que ils
sont en position de force surtout par
rapport à malibu qui est quand même il
faut en parler c'est inès est une ville
qui va être la situation où la guerre
qui actuellement dessus elle va être
tranchantes par rapport à qui va dominer
dans les prochains jours ou à l'avenir
nous arrêter le blocus ça veut dire
haussier parce que les faut dire aussi
que les outils ils sont complètement
épuisé il n'arrive plus à recruter est
des guerriers où des soldats des
combattants et les arrive plus à trouver
de l'appui financier ml sont épuisés ils
ont mis instaurant en plein champ mis en
place et instaurer une à une toutes une
un mécanisme pour essayer de d'avoir de
l'argent de des médicaments et eau est
aussi et des armes est là ils se sont
vraiment épuisé le fait de retirer
blocus sa valeur par permettre aussi de
renouveler d'avoir un nouveau sens de
renouveler aussi leur
l'approvisionnement d'avoir plus
d'approvisionnement à tous les niveaux
donc pour eux c'est très important aussi
que la coalition arrête les raids ou
arrêtent les tirs sur la capitale sanaa
où outre se trouvent principalement afin
de pouvoir se reconstituer se régénérer
et recomposer un peu avec cette
situation
alors vous parlais tout à l'heure vous
disiez que les rebelles houthi avait
l'impression de reprendre la main dans
ce conflit est ce que réellement il
prenne davantage sur le gouvernement
yéménite et ses alliés bon l'arabie
saoudite a aussi perdu son père en
quelque sorte le soutien des etats-unis
sur ce point là exactement qu'est ce
qu'on pouvait nous dire en fait il peut
on peut pas nier que les outils et
depuis plusieurs mois ils ont la main
complètement sur la plus grande partie à
la partie la plus intéressante du billet
mal est là je parle sur le plan longue
seulement sur le plan économique mais
sur le plan démographique parlant de le
gouvernement il n'y a pas réellement un
gouvernement yéménite et un gouvernement
qui agit en fonction de ce qui se passe
quand huit demandes par rapport de
l'arabie saoudite d'une part et un peu
dé la coalition si on peut appeler ça
comme ça
léoty aujourd'hui ils savent très bien
même s'ils sont fatigués même s'il ya
des négociations il faut vraiment
prendre l'air il faut faire le zoom sur
la situation on sait très bien que les
outils ils sont trop attachés on les
associe souvent à l'iran
le changement d'un gouvernement ou le
changement de départ des trains avec by
dell les négociations nucléaires aussi
avec l'iran il ya beaucoup de choses à
prendre en considération par rapport à
cette guerre donc les outils aujourd'hui
savent très bien qu'ils sont bien
avancés qu'ils peuvent très bien gagner
le marais qui est la région qui va être
vraiment très intéressante par rapport à
la lala pardon par rapport à qui va la
voir
mais ils savent très bien que même si
les états unis a interdit la vente
d'armes à l'arabie saoudite mais elle
s'est aussi engagé les états unis à
défendre la frontière de l'arabie
saoudite
donc à mon avis et ça va continuer y
aura pas grand changement nous c'est
vrai qu'il ya des propositions de la
part de martin gray fait de la part de
timothée linder king et d'autres envoyés
plusieurs plusieurs médiations mais à
mon avis ça va continuer et il y aura
pas grand changement est pour eux elle
est temps qu'ils dominent une grande
partie tant qu'ils sont financés
tant qu'ils sont plus écoutés ils ont
ils sont plus populaires sur terra que
le gouvernement yéménite pour ils
reconnaissent aucun gouvernement qui dit
vie pour eux c'est c'est une coalition
qui est en train de tuer des minutes et
ils sont là pour les défendre et ils
vont continuer à mon avis parce qu'ils
n'ont rien à perdre ils sont aussi
soutenus par plusieurs pays
merci beaucoup à vous selena je redis je
rappelle que vous êtes analyste
géopolitique spécialiste du yémen